what's up you beautiful little lavender
sunburnt kid gypsies huh you guys ready
for that yum yum off that pump pump huh
maybe I identify as a lesbian bro you
ever thought about that huh huh
maybe I've got that gender-neutral
hairdo bro because you don't know who I
am
alright you don't know who I am but you
about to find out
welcome to this past weekend this past
weekend all right guys welcome to this
past weekend the date is Monday May 8
2017 a beautiful year I think so far for
most people I am coming to you from
Phoenix Arizona and it is the city that
never seats that's what I call it it's
dry country out here so if you don't
hear a lot of moisture coming through me
it's not my fault that's really the
that's the elements affecting me
I'm eight to live actually in Tucson
Arizona a lot of people don't know that
or maybe you do know that I don't know
I'm judging but I used to live in Tucson
Arizona and that's you know that's not
when I consider shirtsleeve country you
won't see a lot of shirt sleeves down
there you see a lot of turquoise a lot
of women and men collecting turquoise
and lying about their past a lot of
people go there to lie about their past
I feel like and that's Tucson Arizona
and I used to go to a high school out
there even for a semester it's a long
story but I moved back in with my mother
after I got emancipated and I moved out
there to Tucson Arizona and I used to go
to a school that was predominantly
Latino and a lot of the children the
ninos they would fight each other in the
afternoon and an abandoned car wash
across the street from the school and
that was Santa Rita high school and I
would um I would try to learn and be
scared that's mostly what I did when I
went to when I attended school there but
anyhow man I'm out here in the desert
I had a great time this weekend it
stand-up live I want to thank everybody
who came out we had a good turnout but
it is dry country out here you know your
skin will get chapped you'll see people
ducking often alleys and you know
putting lotion on themselves and
Vaseline and each other's necks and you
know almost I don't want to say licking
each other's necks but you see some you
know activities that will create extra
moisture you know I wouldn't be
surprised if you saw a man jerking off
onto his hands or you know jerking off
onto somebody else not even for sexual
reasons but more for like grapes of
wrath' the type of necessity you know I
remember getting a [ __ ] out here in
the desert one time getting a little bit
of oral some oral pleasure and I mean it
was like it was like I mean it was like
feeding a piece of wood to an old snake
you know feeding a piece of uh you know
craftsman's wood or something piece of
dry wood to an old snake it was you know
not good [ __ ] out here because it's
not this country isn't built for it you
know this country is more for you know
letting things get bleached by the Sun
it's more for skin cancer and you know
fancy people I feel like you also have a
lot of wealthy people out here who can
buy a lot of land and they have like an
estate and you know hiding hookers in
their houses and being naughty and being
nasty but I've had a nice time here and
I want to thank everybody that came out
to stand up live in Phoenix it was a
pretty good weekend man you know I was
staying in a beautiful hotel here
downtown Chris Rock was staying in the
same hotel as me he was performing here
on Saturday night so I mean I even got
texts from a lot of my friends who were
coming and saying they couldn't come
that they were going to see Chris Rock
and you know it hurts your feelings a
little bit just because
you want people to come out to the show
so I felt a little bit you know I felt
less than of course ridiculous feelings
because this man is a star you know this
man is a superstar and he's I think he's
he's one of my favorite comedians just
so smart amazing jokes I got to hear him
practicing some of his jokes at the
Comedy Store recently talking about his
infidelities you know we're talking
about cheating on his wife and who he
cheated with and stuff like that and
being very candid and I appreciate that
but we still had a lot of fans that came
out a lot of friends that came out and
made me feel pretty good outside of that
dude honestly I got a little bit
depressed bro I don't know what happened
you know I don't know you know I think
just a lot of traveling week after week
being out running around you know fallen
off my program in the past week you know
I'm staying sober and stuff but I
haven't been going to as many meetings I
haven't been reaching out to to others
that I know could probably use a call
here and there you know try to keep you
know about three calls on my list
everyday of things to do of just
checking in with a friend you know
checking in with somebody who maybe
mentioned a problem or mentioned
something that's going on or somebody
who's having you know just somebody a
human because I find that I can get very
inhumane caught up in you know dancing
around with these electronics and trying
to be a human superhero on different
social media sites and just you know get
caught up in my own world and get caught
up bathed in my ego you know it's
amazing how much time we spend bathing
our egos I do anyway so I just got I
don't know I fell out of my I just fell
out man and I just yesterday I was
pretty depressed I laid in bed a lot
made a whole thing of Snickers dude I
ate an entire thing of those little baby
Snickers and there's something I will
need a big snack
I will I won't eat I won't eat a big
snicker
and I think I don't know if it's I don't
know if I'm a [ __ ] you know or from
just being like a candy [ __ ] or some
kind of little sugar [ __ ] but I will
only eat the little ones the baby ones
you know what I don't know what that
means about me I don't know if it's I
want to be a predator you know I don't
know if it means that I'm I feel like a
damn sugar pedophile really because I
won't eat the big ones I won't do it and
I don't know what that means I think I
need to look into that or probably speak
to someone about that I'm a therapist or
someone who's in the culinary world but
uh but I bought a bag of the little baby
ones man and ate them all
I ate a mole I wouldn't let the cleaning
lady in I didn't want her to see the
wrappers so that was some of my shame
that I'm sharing with you
I got bummed out I just I watched
specials on YouTube about missing
children you know I tend to do that
sometimes I don't know why when I get at
my low and my sober lows I'm watching
specials about missing children on
YouTube and I'm eating baby Snickers you
know as many as I can eat so that's kind
of I guess what went on with me and I
don't know why I felt bad you know I
couldn't really put my finger on it I
tried to fight it some you know when I
was feeling low I went I went for a
workout and that helps some you know I
did a little bit of prayer
you notice speaking of like a higher
power trying to get out of myself you
know I believe in prayer and it doesn't
have to be to God or to Jesus Christ er
to you know all our you know you know
Jewish God or to you know whatever black
God or you know black Santa or whatever
people are praying to it can be in
whatever but I believe in taking some of
the pressure of the world off myself
and asking for help even if it's to a
spirit to a being to a higher power to
whoever your God can be I believe in
that I believe in man because the weight
of the world is heavy the weight of the
world is heavy so I got a little bummed
out man I got caught up just you know
wanted to sleep I would sleep and set my
alarm for about 20 minutes and hope that
whenever I woke up I would feel better
you know and that never works a lot of
times you got to really take action get
moving and I didn't do that I could have
done a better job so that was just so my
weekend man sometimes you have those
days you know and I don't know sometimes
I can't tell when they're coming on when
you just don't feel good you know and
the bummer is that you know I'll call
some of my friends I called a friend and
he was having you could hear he was
spending time with his family and stuff
and I wanted to kind of vent my you know
some of my feelings but I got
embarrassed I guess I didn't want to
ruin his good time by sharing the fact
that I wasn't feeling super keen you
know I wasn't I wasn't Superman and you
know I was Clark Kent and um anyhow you
know I'm not trying to down you with my
feelings but those are some feelings
that I had you know we got some good
calls that came in over the past two
weeks really a lot of people talking
about the future and I know we touched
on it a little bit last week we also
touched on missing persons we had a
special episode in between and I'll get
into the future a little more I want to
talk about that more next week a little
bit about the future so if you're
thinking about hitting the hotline you
know we're not moving on yet in the
program just letting you know if you're
thinking about hitting the hotline that
that number is nine eight five six six
four nine five zero three and I want to
know what some of your concerns are
again about the future I want to talk
about that a little bit more because
some people you know we're like whoa you
know the automated car already exists
and and I know it already exists I'm not
saying it doesn't I'm just saying the
ability to implement those things
successfully into the universe if we
already have function
here I think is extremely far-fetched
you know I think it's a lot tougher than
we think I mean for example the CVS
self-checkout dude I was ready to beat
the [ __ ] balls did I beat the damn
eyelashes off of some you know little
guy he got trying to buy Gatorade I'm
trying to get an orange Gatorade you
notice boost my spirits and they got
five self check out things and this
little guy and he just it wouldn't let
me check out and it thinks I'm stealing
it's the bag is in the wrong place and I
didn't pay for a bag and not already
bought some stuff at the other register
so now I'm at the different register
because there's two entrances to the
store and I'm trying to get a Gatorade
you know and this guy give me a hard
time and it you know and finally I said
you know what - [ __ ] it bro I'll drink
water I'll drink damn tap water and try
to imagine different flavors while I'm
swallowing it because just the
self-checkout [ __ ] doesn't work well you
know when people are angry and then
there's some guy and he just swipes his
little thing on the dam and it beeps and
then everything's supposed to be okay it
wasn't okay you know so I don't know if
we can't get that to work I don't know
how we're going to get some of this
other fancy [ __ ] that everybody wants
you know I don't know I don't mean to be
fired up I'm just I mean I'm just
queefing in my damn brain I feel like I
just don't I don't know man is just a
lone one you know is a long one and when
I get to feeling depressed I just think
stack up fast you know it could just be
a little thing you know uh and then it's
suddenly I'm not that good I'm not a
good person you know write it and I
don't try hard enough you know and then
you know you Chris rocks across the
street and so then it's like oh I'm one
successful you know notice that things
start to add up and then it's like oh
well I'm you know working on the road
and I'm by myself and you know the next
you know I'm doing masturbation just
masturbate
not a shame really or out of just I
don't know just you know just I don't
know just caught up just caught up and
we'll just kind of wallowing like a pig
but my mud is is in action that's what
it is really it's my thoughts because
when I think things don't go well when I
act things go well 100% of the time man
a hundred percent of the time when I
decided to get up and actually go to the
gym run anything go downstairs get a
coffee you know then I started it
creates movement it creates blood flow
anything's possible then things got
better but I got caught up man I got a
caught up in my own circumstances and I
uh you know I was just jerking off and
just eating damn little baby Snickers
and watching the specials on missing
children and I wasn't doing those things
I wasn't you know obviously you want any
self pleasure they need the missing
children I don't do that kind of stuff I
don't have any interest or that that is
not part of my makeup being a PDF file
or having any of that in me
I'm babysat overnight babies had
overnight numerous times and I have five
beautiful nieces and nephews that I love
solely as family members and as
beautiful children that I hope to make
their futures as bright as I can so
anyhow I don't know why I'm saying all
that I don't even know what I'm talking
about at this point but I will say this
it is 1:15 a.m. here in Phoenix time I
believe that specific standard Arizona
is one of the few states that doesn't
change their time so when you set your
clocks forward about word Arizona
doesn't they stand their ground and I
respect that I've always respect that
about Arizona I've always respected that
they got some cool [ __ ] here in Arizona
man if you want to get out and about
we also had people commenting and
e-mailing about
Stevan the guests that we had come in
last week I was happy to have Steven in
when I met him at the DMV he was in more
joyous spirits you know it seemed like
he had up just a built-in pogo stick and
that his feelings were alive inside of
him now when he showed up the other
night for the podcast he seemed like he
may have been under you know he may have
been coming down off of some uppers or
some Sidewinders or something you know
it seemed like he'd been dabbling and
some things you know some spirit Merkers
and it seemed like he was coming in a
little murky and so it was hard it was
tough to conversate he came in late I
only had so much time in the studio but
we did what we could we want him to come
back in next week I hope to be back in
the conscious studios next week or in a
studio right now I'm in a hotel room at
the Palomar hotel here in downtown
Phoenix a beautiful place but next week
I hope to have a guest - I got an
exciting hopeful guest a wig or an adult
wigger or Wigga sorry and I'm not trying
to be offensive but I mean I feel like
that's our word and that's you know a
mammoth aged but who is uh dealt with
you know had that that affinity that
most white people have I feel like the
desire to be black the desire to be
african-american and some people really
practice it heavily I was part of that
group I was a group I was in a group
called NFL when I was young and [ __ ]
for life that was the club and I was a
part of it and we did that when we were
in junior high school and I used to I
used to drive a lot of the brothers my
friends over to school on my bike I had
a bicycle and they would all gang up and
get on the bike and and I would drive
pedal us you know uh I was a conduit
really for to get a lot of young
brothers over to the educational center
there on Jefferson Avenue in Covington
Louisiana but I know an adult wagga one
of the oldest ones that I know and I'm
hoping to have him in studio that's my
hopes I don't know if that's going to
transpire but I'm very hopeful
so hopefully you guys will tune in next
week to that we got some great calls
that came in man we got somebody
considering shooting up their workplace
somebody discussing the fear of missing
out and another job issue somebody else
talking job issues so we're gonna talk
about jobs but also if you guys hit the
hotline in addition to you know worries
or queries about the future I'm also I
want to know the first time you ever
touched some crops if any of you guys
have you know had that experience and I
know some men don't do crotch and female
crotch
or it could be male actually you know it
could be male or female crotch so if you
I want to know that first time you ever
did that I don't need you to get
extremely graphic I don't want that but
I do want to know your feelings you know
some of the feelings you had what did
your friends think what were some of
those what went on there because that's
a really interesting time for a young
man or a young man when that occurs and
it can even be a woman if they got a
women out there and what I call in some
beautiful ladies that want to call in
and just let us know kind of maybe about
some of that experience just because
it's you know that's a unique time in
somebody's life when they first really
get that uh than external crotch
experience whether or not you know just
doing self pleasure or just kind of
digital in their own crops their own
bits so we're going to hopefully I want
to hear a little bit about that too if
some people are willing to share you can
share your experience I just don't need
you to be graphic we're not trying to be
perverts we're not trying to be nasty
but I do want to share it I do want to
know and I'll share some of my
experiences you know because those are
important times and unique times in our
sexuality so I want to discuss that I'm
going to drop a few dates on you really
quick I also want to tell you want
support the podcast you can just be
supportive go to Theo van comm slash
store sto re you can cop on to the
t-shirts we got some neat shirts on
there I think I'm going to maybe give
one that says uh keep calm and Theo von
somebody
recommended that idea it's kind of a
played-out idea but it's something I'm
considering just to keep the podcast in
business you know you can support the
album 30 pound bag of hamster bones it's
available on iTunes right now and then
just you can subscribe only about half
of our viewers are actually subscribed
so if you just want to hit the subscribe
button and just continue to be a part of
what we're trying to do here which I
don't always know what it is you know
but I do appreciate you guys being here
and and listening to me and calling in
because this gives me an opportunity
sometimes to get in touch with who I am
and to look back at my week or weekend
and and find you know some of the joys
and find some of the pitfalls so thank
you very much for that I'll be in Tampa
Bay at the side splitters comedy club
that's May 25th through 28th ok May 20th
we got a show down in Orange County
that's at the hard core fitness studio
and that's in Lake Forest California and
those tickets will go on sale online on
my web site
tomorrow on Monday or Tuesday and that's
May 20th the hard core fitness studio
it's a new show that goes on down there
and I heard it's really great so I'm
excited to go down there and do that in
Lake Forest California again I'll be in
Tampa Florida and that is June 25th no
that is May 25th through 28th I'll be in
Pittsburgh Pennsylvania June 1st through
4th I'll be at the Colusa casino and
that is june night somewhere in
california june 23rd and 24th i'll be at
gotham in new york city new york city
new york you know they call it the same
thing just to piss you off really but
that's new york city new york same place
and that's in the city and then Wyoming
Illinois we're doing a special
fundraiser show if you're wondering
where is that it's a small town 1,500
people beautiful little town my mother
was raised there and she had her dad had
a lot of issues over there and she was a
single child but a beautiful
little town raising money there to save
a theater that's there in town it's near
Peoria it's near Kewanee it's about
maybe an hour from the Quad Cities of
Iowa so you could come down about two
hours from Chicago you could come down
to Wyoming Illinois find your
bed-and-breakfast our hotel and we're
going to make it a fun night that night
two shows 7:00 and 9:00 p.m.
those tickets are all available through
Theo von dot-com slash store all right
guys let's jump into a couple calls here
because I know why people have them and
I want to hear them and let's get into a
man and I'm sorry about telling you guys
I was a little depressed I'd open up
this Diet Coke here because I got to
catch a ride to the airport in about
four hours but sometimes I just you know
I don't know man I just want to be a
happy adult you know and I just sort of
they get scared that I'm not going to be
you know some of us really get scared
that I'm not going to be and I don't
know what a switch I didn't have those
elements inside of me that made me
fearful you know to switch my makeup was
different you know what a swish that I
don't know sometimes of us wish that uh
that I was different all right let's get
him doing some calls here we got a
beautiful gentleman right here who's
having some some issues I think I got an
issue this guy seems like he's going
through some things let's listen to this
guy yeah
cuz I'm from Tacoma Washington Kyle in
Tacoma Washington thank you for calling
dude Tacoma very interesting City if you
haven't been there it's about 40 minutes
from Seattle it's very granola but at
the same time a lot of cowboys there so
you can you know have a mouth full of
granola and raspberries and then you can
have a man or hearty lesbian come and
really kick the [ __ ] out of you at the
same time while you're trying to eat
those things I remember one time I got a
rental car up near Tacoma this true
story and it got dented a lesbian kicked
it at the bar we were at she said it was
her car I said no it isn't I got into
the car she still said it was hers and
so then she kicked it I don't know if
she realized it wasn't hers and just
wanted to kick it her she didn't like it
maybe she hated vehicles you know maybe
she you know maybe I don't know what
could it could transpire with her but we
didn't have the money we didn't get the
insurance on the car you know so to save
money I was over there doing comedy do
we caught a pigeon right and tried to
get this bird to [ __ ] try to hold it
over the dents to get it to [ __ ] on the
car so that they wouldn't see the dents
when we turn the car in and I don't know
if you tried to get a pigeon to [ __ ] you
know when you need it to but it's very
sporadic and it's it's more of a it's
more ma it's a little more feels more
like a scientific than you think you
think it's going to be ease you're going
to hold the pigeon it's going to [ __ ]
cover the dance you're going to you know
not have to deal with insurance issues
when you turn in the rental car but but
the pigeons there's a lot of I guess
nerves inside of them they get nervous
there's not as much feces as you'd
expect out of a pigeon and it was a
bigger issue than than we had thought it
was going to be but anyhow let's let's
get back in a Kyle from Tacoma
Washington what's going on Kyle I
absolutely hate my job on a cellular
level I mean
and it takes every bit of my doom not to
coming to work well ak-47 and kill
everyone in there what for
I wake up in the morning and blow my
[ __ ] brains out across the wall
alright
so Kyle having a tough time out there in
Tacoma man I'm going to stop right now
I'm just going to say look man I
appreciate you calling Kyle you know to
shoot up work or to shoot yourself
commend oh god dude I feel you I feel
you do I used to work at a snow cone
stand and this guy would he would talk
and repeat himself and I almost wanted
to kill him one time and then uh and and
then I realized I can't do that you know
but I feel you thank you for calling
let's continue forth every ever every
single morning I work for the government
I hate the people I work for I like
three people in the whole building I
work and I think are good people the
rest of them I'd be happy if I woke up
and I found out they're all dead
honestly feel what I want to know is
like I I can't leave this organization
for nerve year-and-a-half okay so he's
got to stay there for a while and he's
got these desires to kill and possibly
to kill himself on him you know at least
on a level Riis voicing it so you know a
lot of this could be hypothetical you
know it's a government job I think that
kind of stuff happens there there was a
rampant you know string of post people
shooting up post offices awhile you know
15 years ago and that was pretty hot but
let's continue please I don't care what
it is please man I need some sort of
advice on how to get through this
because I'm it's hard for me not to turn
the drugs and alcohol every day Wow
you know I'm wondering is it just work
that's making you mad you know what
extracurricular activities do you have
going on sometimes you can get mad at
something and you and and and you get
addicted to that anger you know excuse
me I have a diet coke here most of it's
made out of burps and caramel flavoring
that's all it is in the can is wet burps
and caramel flavoring that you pour in
the end and some good bit of it comes
back out but you know college here if
you have that much anger it seems like
you start to manifest the anger more
because you dwell on it you know it's
kind of like when you I can't think of
an analogy right now man I'm just my
brains a little tired but if you you
know if you get addicted to that to that
feeling each day and to hating everybody
then you're going to stay there you're
going to stay there dude
and you know something works for me man
I got some people that I work with that
I [ __ ] can't stand bro
can't stand them and it used to drive me
nuts
and you know what I do you know what I
do dude I pray for those people and it's
crazy because my father used to tell me
one of the only things he told me was to
pray for your enemies and I thought he
was crazy but I guarantee you this dude
you pray for your enemies whoever they
are the people you hate the most the
boss whoever whoever it is pray for them
for two weeks straight and you will be
relieved of whatever
whyever you hate them man I think I've
done this practice and I believe it
because you got to find a way to
transpose that because you used to be
there for a year and a half I mean your
only other option is to shoot the place
up and first of all that's already been
done
honestly shooting up a school shooting
up a government building kind of hack
bro you know I mean it's not it's not a
safe idea you know and I've been that
angry dude I've been that angry I'll
tell you poor
choice I made when I was in junior high
school there at William pitcher junior
high school also offered Jefferson
Avenue and uh and we had a science lab
and I got angry in there because
everybody was cutting up some type of
ducks or something some damn science
thing we had to do you're cutting up a
duck and looking at its insides and they
gave me this [ __ ] duck that was
smaller than everybody else's done and I
got pissed dude and I left the gas on in
the room every little station had a
thing we could turn the gas on and the
room it was on a Friday so Monday
everybody comes back to school the gas
has been on all weekend it's filling
this room up now had somebody used a
little spark earthing in there you know
one of those Bunsen burner igniters or
whatever those little Flint steel
clicker contraption things it makes a
spark whole room would have gone up
right some people accuse me and I
actually accused a mentally handicapped
child at our school I'm not proud of
that but but I didn't know what else to
do and I didn't want to be in trouble
but I'll tell you this man I was
grateful that everybody didn't blow up I
was grateful dude so even though some
time killing everybody seems like a
great idea you know I'm going to say
that it's probably not but I'm going to
say to you I want you to at least come
up with a couple of other ideas of ways
you can solve the problem you know
because if you hate 30 people dude and
they're probably a bunch of [ __ ] dude
they're probably a bunch of [ __ ] DNA
[ __ ] semen gypsies bro you know and I
know I'm angry tonight okay but they're
probably a bunch of damn people that
should be in a cult but don't have the
bravery to do it you know so they work
for the government you know and maybe
that's who they are maybe they're not
but
you you got to deal with it because if
you're at you're angry at 30 people bro
you might be part of the problem call
alright let's finish your call man just
can just let me know what's going on man
thank you
well there you go ma'am and uh and I
think I did let you know what's going on
man and I felt bad I got blamed this
mentally-challenged boy at our school
and you know he and he was one of those
boys his mother made his own made all
his shirts so even if you're not
mentally challenged you look damn
mentally challenged when you or have all
you know shirts of your mother made all
of his shirts had all these religious
quotes sewn into women's stuff and I
mean it was bizarre but I felt happy
that saw that he didn't go to jail he
didn't do any time he had some you know
he had some definitely they you know try
to proceed with some pressing charges
but you know that's neither here nor
there he's doing probably as well as he
could do in life and he's doing fine
from what I've heard I've seen pictures
on facebook he's doing really he's doing
well I was a couple of dogs I see now a
couple labs or retrievers but um but you
know looking back I'm glad I didn't
shoot them I'm glad I didn't blow the
place up man so I think you just kind of
keep thinking keep your mind open keep
your heart open and find better ways to
deal with it man I don't have a ton of
suggestions because I've never worked
for the government but I have wanted to
blow up a roomful of my peers and others
because I got a small dead duck than
everybody else and that right there
shows you that I was the problem you
know these people didn't know that
they're dead ducks we're dissecting
we're going to be big or nobody was part
of that [ __ ] this is this [ __ ] universe
that I created in my head where my ego
was hurt because I'm operating I'm
cutting on a dead duck a mallard or
whatever it was
[ __ ] Mallard and other people are doing
regular-sized dead animals and I felt
less than so if you're turning to drugs
and alcohol dude turn somewhere else bro
you know man up dude I'm tell you that
man up bro all right let's go on to
another caller here
man let's see what we got here a co man
I really appreciate the only podcast
mana I love it you really opening
yourself to everybody and I appreciate
it thank you brother I appreciate you
calling in brother onward the reason why
I'm calling today is because of like a
little bit of your advice from Risley
from America of course but I've been
living in Thailand the last four months
okay you let him in Thailand now a lot
of people go to Thailand to do drugs and
they do uh you know sex parties and
stuff also nice beaches onward and I've
been dating this woman here she is not a
citta she's from Myanmar but he's dating
a Myanmar woman from Myanmar fun to say
fun to say that place Myanmar I don't
know I had this infatuation with her for
a bit but I actually could I ended that
relationship and I just I feel so much
guilt and I just says wants your advice
about how you deal with how you manage
feeling guilty with the break-up because
you know we weren't dating long we had
we had our fair said number of issues
for sure but at the same time I just
feel so guilty no she didn't see a
common it's not something she really I
don't know managers it seemed like I
kind of blindsided her it seemed to me
that we have an issues near the end but
now that I finally excuse me okay so
you're having issues and you broke up
with her and you feel bad about it okay
make sure I'm getting it all it's almost
the end of the call up keep going
finally did it now that finally ended it
that just feels so much guilt I feel I
feel so bad for so I don't know if you
put this on here but kind of rambling a
bit but okay madam is copyright they're
telling you closing up um you are
feeling guilt because you broke up with
someone right I've been there man I
illya dude the hardest thing to do
really is to be honest with somebody and
let them go when you don't feel like
it's a right fit some of the reasons why
I feel guilty or have felt guilty in the
past from my experience is that I was
uncertain you know I didn't trust myself
even though I knew that it was the right
move I just didn't trust myself man I
didn't feel confident in who I was no
matter what decision I was making so to
make a big choice like to let somebody
go that I had cared about at one time at
least decently it sounds like you cared
about this woman
it was very jarring afterwards it's like
you have like returners remorse a little
bit you know I think what you need to do
is just trust your instincts and the
reason you probably feel bad is because
I think one of the reasons could be that
you actually cared and that's okay you
know it would be it would be more
revealing if you didn't feel bad because
then did you really care you know if it
just goes on over your shoulder then you
didn't probably really care that much
but the fact that you you care do you
know you miss her you you think about
her it was close to something that was
probably really good or maybe perfect or
maybe the timing isn't right right now
but the fact that you stood up and said
this isn't going to work for me we'll
probably leave the availability for that
in the future if you guys change because
you man up dude the toughest thing to do
is to [ __ ] do what you got to do you
know you could have meddled around and
texted here and texted there you know I
mean I got girls I probably been texting
on and off with for seven years you know
when I think about it that I'm never
going to meet up with ever but we still
like what are you doing to a sweetie
what you doing tonight maybe we can move
it
just because I'm afraid to cut ties
because I'm a
to be confident that someone better is
going to come to me but it doesn't sound
like that's what's going on with you it
just sounds like you cared and you're
you know you're bummed and you cared
about this girl and you don't want her
feelings to hurt and that's that's nice
of you it's nice that you can empathize
with her but you don't want to make it
so that like you you hurting for her
like you don't want to get kind of
codependent like that or like you know
like oh you know I feel so bad about
what I did I'm going to hurt for her as
well like just make sure you're not
doing that because that's kind of a
place of you know you putting yourself
in the in like the the center of the
universe role where you know every
everyone's feelings have to be you have
to feel everyone's feelings you don't
have to do that you know just make sure
that you know it's just natural
comfortable you know pain discomfort
heartache those things are okay it's
weird that we we got them in this world
these days where it's not okay to feel
those or it's not okay to inflict those
on everybody I think someone that goes
back to the the the environment where
everybody gets a trophy
you know we want to make everybody feel
okay all the time we're afraid to make
others feel almost really to make them
feel we're afraid to commit to love
we're afraid to commit to separation so
I commend you on being fearless about it
man you know a while back I met up with
a girl and we met for some pizza you
know a little bit of Italian you know
circle divided and we spent time there
chatting and eating it was nice but then
I realized immediately I didn't have the
time to devote to getting to know her
better and I just you know she checked
in and I checked in we say we had a nice
time but then I texted I said you know I
think you're great I don't saw at the
time right now
it has nothing to do with you I
appreciate you hanging out with me and
it was probably one of the most adult
things I've done in a while was just
take responsibility do what needed to be
done and even if she said oh I wasn't
even thinking like that or whatever
that's fine I'm just taking care of my
side of my street so that my feelings
aren't milling around with split ends
you know so anyway I like what you're
doing man you know and just feel that
pain and feel what it feels like you
know feel what it feels like to you're
not being a bad guy you know but it's
nice that you care that you have some
empathy and you concern for her feelings
you know and I think that's okay I mean
it's tough you probably want to check in
and be like are you all right in this in
that but she's an adult man she's an
adult and she'll be okay you know if she
you know leaves you a voicemail saying
she might shoot up her workplace or
whatever then maybe she's not even a
woman maybe she's actually our first
caller Kyle so anyhow man onward let's
take one more call here and see what's
going on thank you guys for listening
and I'm awfully tired but I appreciate
you guys sticking with me again I'm
gonna give you that hotline number I
need some good voicemails I'm going to I
want to get it interactive and as soon
as we can get this locked in the studio
we'll do some live calls and I want to
get there and I appreciate you sticking
with me that number is nine eight five
six six four nine five zero three if you
mess up your voicemail leave it again
that's okay that's totally okay and
we're going to create an email next week
where you can email issues that you want
me to discuss on the show as well but I
don't have that yet because I want to go
to sleep man I want to go to sleep for
two and a half hours before I go to the
airport and I love you guys but I don't
[ __ ] love you that much dude and I'm
trying not to masturbate and I'm you
know coming off this weird sugar high
dude where you know I mean I'm gonna
[ __ ] Froyo based on the fact of how many
damn you know baby Snickers I've had in
the past 24 hours
anyhow one more call let's get to it
right here here we go
hey what's up vou mullet Gandhi
appreciate the show I'm a big fan and
I'm calling in man I need mullet Gandhi
that's kind of funny man it's kind of
it's 50 percent funny maybe 70 percent
thank you for that oh we're some advice
I just hit 34 stuck in a job that I
really don't like it pays the bills but
you know I just need some direction and
it seems like it's been 10 years now and
I'm still looking for that direction and
just trying to figure out what to do for
work you know no sense being stuck in a
job that I hate but been at it for you
know 10 years now so if you could give
me some advice okay man so you 10 years
you've been the same job you don't
really you know you think it's that you
think you hate it you know you're not
sure but you're making money you're
paying your bills well is there
something else you want to do I think
it's where you start and maybe you don't
know I mean look man I do comedy right I
do this comedy job I've been doing it
for 14 years now for twenty five
weekends a year I've been on the road
slanging [ __ ] dirt riddles up and
down the damn coast and [ __ ]
everywhere okay and there there's two
days a week Ronald's know if that's what
I want to do you know the greatest day I
ever had in my life that brought me the
most joy I was in India one time India
the country and I've worked at a
disabled children's home
cleaning out a yard that they needed
cleaned because it was full of debris
and [ __ ] and they were going to
build a playground there and that was
the only day of my life where I got to
the end of my day and I felt useful as a
human being so do I think that this is
what I want to do forever do I think I'm
being of the most service that I can be
as a human I don't know you know I don't
know so I understand you think in those
things you know I'd find what brings you
joy and maybe
start to experiment with that on the
side because you have to continue to pay
your bills you have to continue to work
you know I you have to work I live with
a friend of mine for a while and his dad
who was an alcoholic as well and you see
to see those chips all the time and he
and I would take turns sneaking out to
the computer to watch pornography
because they only had one computer there
at the house but his dad said you got to
work that's what he told me he said you
got to work so you have to be working
you know you got to be contributing how
to be keeping your flow going so I keep
the job in so you have another idea
so I'd experiment some things on the
side and if you find that you you don't
have something else that pops into your
head then maybe just you maybe that work
isn't a place where you need to find
your joy you know or sometimes your joy
can come from somewhere else we've
attached our joy I feel like these days
to our work your joy could come from
anything it could come from being a
great parent it can come from being a
great son maybe you want to be a better
nephew maybe you want to be up you know
a craftsman you know maybe you want to
sing I mean you can find another place
to find your joy then your work will
just be this secondary thing that you do
and your true joy in life can still come
from somewhere else your success and
your life can be being a father
it can be being a son those are great
jobs man those are jobs we need in this
world you know people aren't doing those
jobs anymore those are jobs that we need
people to take seriously the most joy
that I feel these days is when I'm
around my family and dude I never
thought I would say that growing up my
family and I hate each other you know my
brother beat me with a chair once I'm a
very expensive antique chair and and you
know I never thought that I would find
the most joy in my life coming from my
family but these days it warms my heart
a lot of times when I think of the
people that love
and that I'm able to have that accept my
love and that might be my legacy in this
world just the fact one day to know that
I was a loving brother or sibling or
father and those can be a lot of our
successes you know so I implore you to
look in other places to find what may be
your successes your calling is and if
you have some side items some things you
want to try for work than doing you know
experiment but stay busy in the meantime
stay working have an exit plan before
you exit you know don'ts don't just get
out there I don't think that's the
smartest idea you got to keep paying
your bills you may be providing for
family I don't know you didn't mention
that but they're going to want to eat
they're going to want to keep eating you
know so just stay on your
responsibilities and don't be bored if
you're not really experimenting with
other things and you're just going to
work and then just saying you know life
work well well you're not doing that
other side we're actually getting out
there and looking at other possibilities
so until you're willing to do that you
know you can't really say you know I
don't like my job but if you're not you
know really out experimenting to find
out what else you do like then yeah
maybe you don't like your job but you
like it enough that you're willing to
stay there and not even experiment with
other options a little side you know low
side a little side piece work you too
little side piece something you you know
you can still be banging your wife your
job but you can kind of be you know
jerking off on your side piece in the
meantime you know until you see if ah
that side piece could become a new wife
so that is those are the some of my
thoughts I don't know if that's super
helpful or not to but it's the middle of
the [ __ ] night bro and and it's been
a long weekend you know what I'll get to
one more man I'll get to one more year
what's going on here actually you know
what I'll do it next week man
I got to follow up we had a guy who
reached out to a while back and I'll
drop that later on this week we're also
going to drop i'ma start dropping sand
thanks for my history every from the
in my career and stuff on Fridays from
the vault so that will come out this
Friday I gave you those dates we'll get
back into having some intro and outro
music I've had some amazing fans and
friends that have reached out offering
to create some so I'm looking forward to
getting into that and I just want to
thank you guys for supporting and
bearing with me and and for just being a
part of my life each week you know I
don't know what we're on to here but
we're on to something and I'm going to
try to just keep showing up and and you
guys just try to keep showing up and
let's just keep figuring life out dude
you know we're still alive you know we
made it it's just another Monday that's
all it is you know this this day doesn't
define us there's just a little piece in
the big puzzle of whoever we're going to
be you know this isn't our ending this
is just another opportunity to be a
little bit better than we were last week
you know progress not perfection if
you're trying to be perfect you got to
shut that down you got to shut it down I
try it and that's why I end up laying in
bed doing masturbation wondering where
this kid in Oregon has gone to and
eating small Snickers because sometimes
my brain logs back in and tells me I'm
not perfect
yeah well that's fine brain you know but
I'm going to tell you right now I'm
going to tell you to your face dude
you're right I'm not perfect but I'm not
a bad person you know and and I'm making
progress you know and I care and I care
about myself you know scary as it is to
say that sometimes dude you know that's
one thing I've noticed recently in my
life is for some reason it's scary for
me to admit that I care about myself
I don't know why I don't if it's just
for so long I didn't care but for some
reason it's scary for me to admit that I
care about myself so
I don't know we learn as we go but
progress not perfection and I thank you
guys for joining me this week on this
past weekend I implore you to be good to
yourself because I bet you deserve it
man you know I really bet you do
I'll see you guys soon all right thank
you so much for the support subscribe if
you haven't subscribed tell your friends
to check out the pod I'm eternally
grateful to to some of my podcast
brothers who who gave me opportunities
to be on their podcast and have helped
me learn some of the ropes and inspire
me Joe Rogan Coco Diaz the fighter and
the kid you know I got a text from Joe
the other night after I did a comedy set
and he said hey man that was a great set
you know and I didn't know he was
standing there watching or anything like
that
and he didn't have to do that you know
but it was just nice it's nice when we
if we have any experience in something
if we reach out to somebody younger
who's new or novel into the same
environment and just cheer them on it's
amazing how far that goes you know it
meant a ton of me when I was a kid when
somebody did that if somebody showed
interest and it's funny it still
resonates with me when I'm an adult so
yeah so today if you're thinking about
yourself and you think you having a
tough day or tough time or something I
want you maybe just reach out to
somebody else who's younger than you or
who is newer it work than you you know I
know if you only got a year and a half
left you think about shooting up the
place did it just text somebody who just
got it to the place to the workplace you
just started there and be like dude this
is going to come a time you're gonna
want to shoot this place up don't do it
you know or just share something nice
man it's amazing um how how we all have
the power to do somebody spirits you
know sometimes you just forget that and
I'm going to try to remember that today
as well I'm gonna try to get out of
myself and get back onto my program of
reaching out to others and just quit
thinking about me so my brain thinks
about me dude it doesn't think the best
about me that's what's wrong with my
brain
you know but when it thinks about other
people it really cares so I'm just going
to try to live right there and hopefully
I'll be in a better mood next we got
appreciate you guys listening to me then
all this [ __ ] be good to yourselves
man take care thank you this past
weekend
[Music]